When Marc Hayutin was 69, he was diagnosed
with squamous cell thymic carcinoma,
a deadly cancer that affects the lymphatic
and endocrine systems.
His doctor told him he likely had months to
live.
One of the most frightening things I've ever
seen was sort of by accident
when I saw on a medical consultant's laptop
the scan
metastasized to lungs, liver, thoracic cavity,
my right humerus, my left scapula.
That was six years ago.
He survived thanks to an experimental drug
that rapidly shrank his tumors and eased his pain.
What's particularly noteworthy about Marc
Hayutin's surprising recovery
was that the drug that saved his life hadn't
been approved by the FDA.
That would come six years later,
at which point Hayutin probably would have
been long dead.
He was able to take it anyway thanks to Right
to Try—
a legal movement that has led to the passage
of laws in 41 states
allowing doctors to prescribe terminal patients
with experimental drugs
That haven't passed muster with regulators.
Some bills, they don't have a good name, okay?
they really don't.
But this is such a great name, for the first
day I heard it, it's so perfect 'Right to Try.'
In May of 2019 President Trump signed right
to try into federal law.
It was championed by Vice President Mike Pence
who had signed a version of the legislation
himself in 2015.
Whatever happens next, I've had a great quality
of life, we've continued to travel,
we've been able to take our grandchildren
on trips.
Marc Hayutin's story underscores the deadly
consequences of FDA overreach.
The Right to Try laws which were engineered
by a small free market think tank in Arizona
called The Goldwater Institute,
are a shot across the bow of the FDA's core
mission.
It's a real culture change in Washington DC,
it's one of the first times in recent history
where congress has told the FDA
'you're over stepping your boundaries.'
And I think that that's not the end of the
story, this is just the beginning.
Concern over the tragic effects of the new
sedative thalidomide
prompts president Kennedy at his press conference
to call for stronger, better administered
drug laws.
Founded in 1906, the Food and Drug Administration
didn't become a powerful force in american
health care until the 1960s
when the sedative called thalidomide was marketed
to pregnant women in Europe.
It turned out that when their mothers took
thalidomide
about 40% of babies died in utero or shortly
after birth.
Those that survive often had severe birth
defects like shortened limbs and deformed organs.
Americans mostly dodged the thalidomide tragedy
thanks to FDA physician Frances Oldham Kelsey
who was concerned about its safety and kept
it off the US market.
Her decision saved thousands of lives and
earned her the presidential medal of freedom.
At the time the FDA's mandate
was to determine if a drug had dangerous side
effects before approving it for use.
After the thalidomide scandal a new law gave
the agency broad authority
to determine if new drugs also did what they
claimed
and to prevent americans from trying them
until it's investigation was complete.
It turned out there was an enormous cost to
caution.
Thalidomide's hidden victims were those denied
access to life saving medicines
because of regulatory overreach.
In the decade after the FDA expanded its scope,
new drug approvals fell by about two thirds.
Today the average cost to get a drug passed
the FDA to market has risen to 2.7 billion dollars.
And the number of new drugs approved per billion
dollars spent
has halved every nine years since 1960.
And yet there was little public outrage over
the impact on medical innovation.
Images of children deformed in utero by an
untested drug spur public action.
But the victims of a regulatory environment
that limits access and curbs innovation go
unnoticed.
But libertarian reformers at the Goldwater
Institute
discovered one scenario that the public could
rally around.
Cases in which terminally ill patients are
denied the right to try experimental drugs.
David Huntley who suffered from ALS,
a neuro-degenerative disease that destroys
all motor function
fought for access to a drug in clinical trials
that could slow the progression of his disease.
FDA impeded his access to GM604, a potentially
life altering treatment.
Without any treatment I will pas in 3 to 9
months.
How is keeping a potentially life saving drug
from me saving my life?
The decision to use an investigational drug
to fight a fatal disease
should be between a patient and his or her
doctor.
Huntley died in 2015 and never got access
to GM604
which is in limbo after completing phase 2
clinical trials.
In September 2016 ALS sufferers testified
before Congress.
Right now we have no hope, so it's either
hope or no hope.
And this bill, it doesn't do everything,
but it moves us in the direction of having a little bit of hope.
When chemotherapy failed to shrink Marc Hayutin's
tumors
there were no FDA approved treatment options
left.
But he was accepted into a clinical trial
run by Dr Ebrahim Delpassand
a nuclear oncologist testing an experimental
drug call lutetium-177 Dotatate.
It turned out to have very few side effects.
Many of our patients, if you look at them,
you can't even tell that they are undergoing
cancer therapy.
So typically they don't lose their hair, they
don't get sick.
My cough disappeared, the tumors started to
shrink
and people literally thought I was cured.
Nobody knew why it was working, but it was
working.
At the end of the final phase 3 clinical trial
the drug had eliminated tumors in a majority
of patients.
After the trial concluded two and a half years
went by before the FDA would approve the drug.
In the meantime Dr Delpassand requested permission
from the agency
to continue administering it to participants
like Hayutin
who were being kept alive by the treatment.
and to new patients with endocrine cancer.
Many cancer patients they can't wait.
The disease in an advanced phase and if we
lose that momentum,
if we do not give them the treatment on time,
essentially we lose that opportunity to control
the disease.
His request was denied.
It was a very difficult time for me at that
point
because what can I tell these patients and
their family members?
Hayutin asked the FDA to reconsider.
The FDA wrote a nice letter to me saying
'well thanks very much but we can see you
didn't in fact have a complete response.'
and I said 'well maybe not,
but I would have been dead before I was writing
this letter without the response I did have
and only a few cancers have the possibility
so far of complete responses.'
The odds are already so stacked against the
patient
it doesn't help to have the FDA taking positions
like this.
The FDA should never be the decision maker.
The FDA can require testing, the FDA can make
sure that people have enough information
so that they can make good decisions.
But at the end of the day it should be the
patient and the doctor
who are the ones that are making the decision.
The Goldwater Institute presented the problems
that Dr Delpassand's patients were having
to the Texas legislature.
Which quickly passed a Right to Try law.
Hayutin got continued access to the treatment
as did 77 of Delpassand's other patients.
In the roughly two years between when the
FDA told him to stop giving these treatments to patients
to when the treatment was finally approved
for market, he treated about 200 patients.
And many of them were told they only had months
to live and many of them are still alive today.
Though the FDA declined our interview requests,
the agency has emphasized it's own expanded
access program called compassionate use
which allows some terminal patients to try
experimental drugs.
According to a 2017 government accountability
office report
the FDA approved 5697 of 5753 requests
that came through the compassionate use program
between 2012 and 2015.
Critics argue that because of this program
Right to Try laws are superfluous.
But before Right to Try getting approval through
compassionate use
involved significant bureaucratic hurdles.
According tot he nonprofit Regulatory Affairs
Right to Try state laws pressured the FDA
to streamline the application process.
Delpassand used the FDA's expanded access
program to provide some of his patients with the drug
but once the drug was on track for commercial
approval,
the FDA wouldn't let him enroll any new patients.
It was only through Texas' right to try law
that the rest of Delpassand's patients, including
Hayutin,
were able to continue to get their treatment.
I wouldn't be sitting here talking to you
now
if compassionate use was all that I had.
Right to Try allows pharmaceutical companies
to sell experimental drugs at cost
and unlike compassionate use, protects them
from liability and reporting requirements
if a patient dies or suffers on account of
a bad reaction.
No pharmaceutical in their right mind would
give me a drug compassionately
because if I have an adverse event, which,
you know, I'm an ALS patient
let's face it, I probably will, they have
to report that to the FDA
and it's gonna jeopardize their trial.
Drug approvals have been derailed in the past
by adverse effects occurring under compassionate use.
A patient should be able to weigh the potential
that the drug might now work
or the drug might have very serious side effects
against the potential that the drug could
actually save their lives.
Nobody can make that decision for a patient.
That is up to the individual themselves.
Not a drug company, not a doctor and certainly
not the FDA.
Critics also say Right to Try has only helped
a small number of patients so far.
Although there are no official numbers to
date.
Sandefur says that she expects that to change
as drug manufacturers and doctors become more
familiar with the law.
Right to Try is a very small but a very important
first step in the right direction.
Ultimately I would love to see a system that
is more patient centric.
I would love to see a system that gives patients
more options
so that they don't have to be beholden to
the FDA.
And that's especially true of terminally ill
patients
because when people are fighting for their
lives
they shouldn't have to fight the government
as well.
Sandefur says that the Right to Try
is just the beginning of the push for greater
pharmaceutical freedom.
Policy researcher Bartley Madden for example
has floated a proposal, already being implemented
in Japan,
under which any patient could access experimental
drugs that pass initial safety screenings
without any FDA involvement at all.
Their outcomes would be logged in publicly
accessible databases
enabling a freer flow of information and possibly
faster breakthroughs.
Thanks to Right to Try, Marc Hayutin has lived
for six years
beyond his doctor's initial expectations.
Time that he's spent with his wife of 54 years,
vacationing with his grandchildren
and caring for his elderly mother.
But recently his cancer returned and he's
now searching for another miracle.
I don't know how soon this journey will end
but I am really grateful for Right to Try.